the angry pissed-off negative unruhe
social state you can't do anything well
stop waking up like an accident
people think I have this gift I'm a
Superman or something and it's not I'm
just like anybody else I'm just very
aware of my emotions rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it's up in my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
manage your state over to you Jordan
Belfort you're an angry pissed-off
negative on resourceful state you can't
do anything well you've got one of those
days for instance where everything
you're doing you're like I can't believe
I said that I can't believe I did that
I'm such a fool right yeah that day
we've all had that day yeah next day
similar situation you're like wow you
know that was me I did a really great
job right you were perfect so one day
you're brilliant next day same situation
you're brutal that's not talent that's
not ability that's the state that you're
in
so the key to success is not just a to
have your vision but to be able to
manage the way you feel in the moment
now if you're a parent what's the most
resourceful state patience if you're a
businessman looking to make money on
Wall Street it's probably certainty yeah
more courage because fear is the worst
emotion of all for being a trader on
Wall Street so every business has
different states that you need to master
now in most businesses in matters of
wealth is straight three states that you
need to master feel the trigger and a
moment's notice and it's easy to do once
you learn how we're just going to teach
people okay and number one is certainty
to be certain about what you're doing
the second one is clarity to be clear
it's not to be overwhelmed with the
obvious will be overwhelmed and the
third is courage is to have a conviction
to know that you might not be right all
the time but you got to let fear stop
because if there's one distinction that
between the wealthy people the world
and the pulpit of the world is that
wealthy people act in the face of fear
while poor people run away from farad
your emotional state matters and you
know what I'm talking about you've had
days where you felt motivated and bold
and courageous and something happened
maybe you watched a video like this
you're listening to a podcast or you
went to an event and you just had that
emotional state of courage and boldness
and amazingness and you went off and
were massively productive for the rest
of the day and you took steps that you
didn't think you were capable of before
and things that were you were putting
off and we're being delayed and just
weren't happening now suddenly started
happening and then you've had days where
you were depressed and low I'm feeling
sorry for yourself and you were not
courageous and feeling Who am I to go
off into that crazy thing and as a
result you don't have a great day you
don't create amazing things and this is
the problem most entrepreneurs are not
consistent we've had moments in our life
where we felt the boldness and the
courageousness and we've taken massive
action we've started these businesses
and we've done crazy things and then
we've also had these moments of weakness
and lack of courage and not following
through and this is constant
rollercoaster up and down and up and
down and up and down here's a solution
this is the problem and the solution
this is so critically important that if
you start doing this it'll have a
dramatic change on the trajectory of
your business and your life stop waking
up like an accident
stop waking up and falling into your day
understand the critical importance of
emotional state and design your day
every day to create an amazing emotional
state for yourself I'm in a pretty good
state right now I'm making videos for
you I'm pretty pumped I'm happy I'm
creating content I love what I'm doing
right now but I don't wake up every day
feeling amazing I wake up pretty much
every day tired rubbing my eyes
wondering what's happening I don't wake
up in an amazing motional state and to
think here's I'll show you right now
here's what I do here's what I do every
single
I'm taking you I'm taking you to my
bathroom we're filming in the bathroom
look this is what I do every day I read
a page for my top ten rows of success
and I drink a glass of water I come into
the bathroom every single morning I wake
up first thing I do go to the bathroom
read a page in the book I get hit with
inspiration it's why I wrote that book I
wanted to get a hit with inspiration
from people who've accomplished huge
things bigger things and I've ever done
huge amazing things that motivate me to
want to create boldness I read one page
I get to great ideas and I sit on it it
takes me two minutes to read the page
three minutes of thinking and in five
minutes my mindset is aligned my state
is amazing I drink a glass of water
because I'm dehydrated first thing in
the morning and then I go off and I
create and I make first thing usually
after that is an Instagram video for you
guys something that I'm passionate about
and I'm set for the day in five minutes
I've adjusted my state to allow me to
have an amazing day now for you it might
be something different like maybe you
hate my book that's amazing I don't care
you got to find the thing and the good
news is you already know you already
know the thing you've already had
moments in your life of feeling bold and
courageous and unstoppable just reverse
engineering what was leading up to that
point what helped you feel that boldness
what helped you feel that courageous say
what was it that got you feeling so
excited and unstoppable and then put
that into your morning routine every
single day put that into your morning
routine I guarantee you I guarantee you
here's a promise this is one of the most
powerful things that you can ever do in
your life I guarantee you if you found
the thing that made you feel bold and
unstoppable
whatever that was a video a book a
podcast whatever that was and you put
that into your morning routine so you
stopped waking up like an accident and
did something powerful every single
morning if you got that state of feeling
bold and courageous Nasseri
single day I guarantee you that your
life one year from today will be totally
unrecognizable will be totally different
than where you are right now because it
will force you to go off and do amazing
pull things that you want to do it'll
force you to chase your goals and do
things that you thought you are
incapable of a year ago and so I really
really really if I could pass one thing
on to you that would be it
stop waking up like an accident plan
your morning routine that you have
boldness built in and I promise you I
promise you amazing things will happen
guys that really special bonus clip for
you but before getting to that question
of the day I want to know what is the
thing that gets you feeling bold
unstoppable and confident what is that
thing that you're gonna put into your
morning routine now leave it down the
comments below really curious to find
out thank you so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus clips
[Music]
so I think people think I have this gift
I'm a Superman or something and it's not
I'm just like anybody else I'm just very
aware of my emotions
you see I learned to manage my emotions
you know because it's so important to be
honest with yourself one of the one of
the things that I find the most is
people are not honest with themselves
and so you have to work with your
calmness and your assertiveness you know
for example if a dog is very dominant
you can't come with calm energy easy
it's gonna take over you so you gotta
step up your assertiveness so the dogs
see okay you understand how to play this
game it's like a wah-wah where's that
but then the repeating factors of my
life have been application discipline
focus repetition you know a gig a gig
again what are you doing tomorrow 8
o'clock on stage we're doing the night
after I'll be on stage we're about two
months from now I'll be still on that
same tour because I manage myself I know
where I'm going I might finish it I
might not survive it but I'm the one
book in it if you try to control the
variety of situations that may pop up in
your face tomorrow morning all that'll
happen is you will become a very limited
life you would step out into the world
and do whatever that needs to be done
only if you have an assurance no matter
what you walk into you will not lose
yourself you will walk full stride
otherwise you'll only be a half a step
most human beings are half steps because
the fear of suffering if this happens
what will happen to me that happens what
will happen to me if you're well managed
within yourself you know how to manage
your thought you know how to manage your
emotion you know how to manage your body
your chemistry your energy if you know
how to manage all this what does it
matter if you walk into hell I'm asking
if you are well managed if you are a
heaven within you what does it matter
where you go
he'll also will be an interesting place
to go but if you are ill managed then
you want to be in a nice place all the
time you will not step out into anything
I am NOT saying this is wrong this is
against nature because in nature
every life is aspiring to a B as much as
it can be isn't it every life is
naturally aspiring this is not a
philosophy this is not an ideology that
you must do this or that it is natural
and intrinsic for every life that you
will do as much as it can from an
earthworm from a worm to an insect to a
bird to an animal to a tree every one of
them are trying to be full-fledged life
if you go against this simply because of
the fear of suffering then all
possibilities of exploring the nature of
being human the tremendous immensity of
being human is just lost upon humanity
today you will see this everywhere when
people say I am only human they are
talking about the limitations of being
human they are not talking about the
possibilities of being human isn't it
when if we are the most intelligent
species on the planet if we are the most
capable species on the planet should we
be talking about our possibilities or
should we be talking about our
limitations
whenever anybody writes or says oh we
are human they are always referring to
their limitations never to the
possibilities of being human this is
because the the most fundamental things
have not been taught in our education
systems how to handle your thought and
your emotion your psychological drama
has gone out of control it's a badly
directed drama believe me if you do the
well directed drama you would take you
to the conclusion that you want isn't it
because it's a badly directed drama just
about anybody can take charge of it who
is the director of your psychological
drama just about anybody
isn't it anybody can make it into your
tragedy raise your standard Apple at the
core is core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the world not one
drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details